grimes and elon musk welcome baby number
two
in a new interview with vanity fair the
33 year old musician reveals that she
and the 50 year old tesla ceo privately
welcomed a baby girl via surrogate
recently and get this turns out baby
girl actually spilled the beans herself
the journalist notes that during the
in-person sit-down a baby started crying
from the other room after grimes had
already confirmed that the pair's 22
month old son x ash a12 aka baby x
wasn't home oopsie
the journalist asked the musician if
she'd welcomed another baby and while
grimes was initially hesitant she
eventually confirmed the news as for the
newborn's name she goes by the letter y
which like her brother is just a
nickname grimes tells the mag her full
name is exa dark sidereal musk and the
singer breaks down the meaning behind
the unique moniker explaining that exa
is a reference to the super computing
term exaflops the ability to perform one
quintillion floating point operations
per second
as for dark grime says it's the unknown
adding that people fear it but truly
it's the absence of photons dark matter
is the beautiful mystery of our universe
and sidereal according to grimes it's
the true time of the universe star time
deep space time not our relative earth
time it's also a nod to her favorite
lord of the rings character galadriel
who chooses to abdicate the ring
[Music]
of course elon and grimes welcomed their
first child ex back in 2020. i don't
want to make little axe too famous so i
you know we can move past this quickly
but that's my very cute little guy doing
sort of like a cyber
madonna photo shoot that my friend
simone took this picture he's just as
you can see exceptionally cute
don't want to give him too much airtime
and last fall the billionaire
entrepreneur who also has five sons from
a previous relationship confirmed that
he and grimes had split after three
years of dating telling page six in
september that they are semi-separated
but still love each other adding that
they see each other frequently and are
on great terms and if you're wondering
where the two stand now amid the latest
little edition grimes told vanity fair
that they're simply happy she says they
live in separate houses but they're best
friends and see each other all the time
quote we're very fluid we just have our
own thing going on and i don't expect
other people to understand it this is
the best it's ever been we just need to
be free
but on thursday after the article
dropped grimes tweeted that they broke
up again still though she calls him the
love of her life and while the two are
pretty private about their personal life
grimes did open up about motherhood
while getting ready for the 2021 met
gala i think having a baby was a big
kind of like rebirth for me i like
artistically like it just like i don't
know being a mother feels weird to say
for some reason i don't like identify
with that word which is also really
weird because ex he says claire but he
doesn't say like mama which is so i'm
like how are you
like maybe he can like sense my
distaste for the word mother which i
don't even know i have a distaste for it
because i like respect with i just i
don't i can't identify with it weirdly
and shortly after that it was with
grimes on the met carpet
you look amazing
do you feel ever been amazing in this
yeah i actually i think it's my favorite
look ever i feel good what inspired this
look um it's kind of inspired by the
movie dune which uh
isn't it's an american film americans
work on it so it's your picture team how
long did it take to get you into this
number tonight only a couple of hours
like two minutes to get into the dress
this is made out of them
from russet guns oh my god
you're on security detail tonight too
have so much fun
[Music]
you